Hi guys. I think I'm live. Let me get set up here.
There you are. All right. I believe I'm live.
I guys. Okay.
So today I get sent a lot of workout gear
and I'm like, all right,
it's probably good for you guys for me to know,
to let you know how it fits, how it feels, what I like, what I don't like,
because a lot of us all order those leggings and sports bras,
and we're just not sure how they fit.
And I'm going to give you some honest reviews.
So there's that because I was about to go to the gym and I was like, wait,
let me just share with you guys. Cause I put on an outfit. I'm like,
this is not comfortable.
So let me just share with you how my honest opinions
about this workout gear. So to begin, um,
I'm wearing, let's see, this is all back up.
So this is under Armour.
The bottoms you can see and the top
is white box.
So my reviews on this is the pants
feel. They're not, I'm not getting enough compression here.
I love the colors. I love me on for the gym. I think it's super fun and bright.
Um, but I'm feeling like you could see right here.
It's not really that supportive.
So I wish I had more compression here and on the thighs,
but I do like the fact that they're high-waisted because I got them holiday, uh,
games. So yeah,
this makes me feel better about going into the gym and I'm in Miami.
So I don't really like wearing layers and layers of clothing.
I'll go to the gym just like this. And I want to feel like still like,
uh, supported and this top, as you can see,
it makes me feel super supported.
But I also feel like I'm risking a nip slip here and I don't
like the padding in it actually would rather,
this is the packing inside. And actually, so you'd rather take that out.
This is like, um, I know I have a pimple there. Um,
so I don't know if you guys can really see, I'm trying to make it.
So that's the padding that's inside. So this side is without the Patti now,
and then this side is with the Patty, but I hate padding him,
especially thick padding.
I know it's probably good cause I have bigger boobs,
so I don't really need this. I know it like hides the nipple, which is great.
But um,
now I feel even better because I don't feel like I'm like going to
the gym, but um, it looks,
it makes your boobs look great, but again,
and it's also pretty supportive, but I'm the mirror over here.
That's what I'm looking at out. But again, I just,
I don't know. I feel a little bit squishy. Maybe it's a size too small for me,
but I like the open back. Um, so the swipe box,
this is under Armour again, as you can see,
like can do squats in it and they are comfy.
Like I would wear these around the house more than I would wear them to the gym.
But it's one of those situations where you're also like pulling up. Um,
but I like the mini on accents and it ties the outfit together.
Even though it's two different brands,
I'm reading your guys' comments. Okay, cool.
So now I'm going to try on another outfit that I
have, which one should I do next?
I'm going to do this one because actually, um,
a lady in my building gave these to me from this brand because she went to
LA and she was like, Oh, this brand is awesome.
And it feels really nice. Um,
this is drip, drip, drip do.
This is by I hadn't. I took off the tags.
Well, a good thing is there's not a lot of tags on this,
so they won't bother you. There's literally no name on this.
There has to be, Oh my gosh. There's nothing.
There's nothing on here. Wait, I had another one.
I think it was like in the garri or something like that.
Yeah. Oh, okay.
It is
gamma and I G a M a soul. Oh yeah,
you got on the soul. So this says, um,
the brands and I think it says they're
like 90 bucks a legging.
So I'm going to try these on they're super thin as you can see. And,
um, it comes with the matching sports bra. I like the pattern.
I think it's really cute. It's like a mermaid. Um, so I'm going to try this on.
Maybe, can you entertain them while I tried this on?
Maybe. Okay.
He's worried.
Sorry guys. So I'm going to try this one real quick and we'll be right.
Cool.
I'm in the, in the other room or
my website in the comments,
um, uh,
love you from Kenya, Kenya,
Ragnar. What is you on is doing you?
Honest was working on his computer for his website,
but now he's here reading the comments. Um, man,
this is a strong sports for a book book book.
All right. What's your plan for 2020?
We're giving one, a nice Anita bond.
Bowser your bottle. What is your honest?
Do it again? We're here. All right guys.
So this is another outfit. Um,
that's when I was just talking about, so a few things I don't,
again, the patterns are super cute. You can see the issue I'm having.
I think with the bra, again,
these pads inside,
aren't really doing their job of just covering up the nipples
or um, and it's not that supportive. Maybe it's more of like a yoga bra.
Um,
but then the pants are actually super cute and I get a lot of compliments on
this. I do wish that the lines went a little higher,
but um, overall it's cute. It's a cute outfit. I like it.
And it's really comfy. But again, um, the sports bra,
isn't a high impact sports bra. It's more of a
[inaudible] or yoga type sports bra. And with that, like,
I like how it has opened back because if you have closed back,
you get a lot of back sweat and you break out.
So that's why I have a pimple right there.
And that's because of the sports bra. Um, but yeah,
so this is really cute.
I think it would look really cute too with like a flowy tank with an open back.
Um, yeah, I can do the pants are,
I love how I always demonstrate with the squat, but the pants that are,
you feel good, they go down a little when I squat,
I'm trying to give you like every angle over view,
like over all of these clothes are great, but, um,
there's things that could be better. So cute.
I wish this was up more.
I almost don't make it cause it's like a mid-rise and I really like the
high-rise pants and as a personal preference, I other like at low or like,
um, but yeah, and I want to feel like, again, these are free.
These are more yoga type pants because you feel the compression
here, which is great. But here I feel like it like goes down a little bit. Yeah.
I love you guys too. Um,
yeah, so again, I'm not a fan of the padding,
especially with lighter sports bras,
just because like lighter colors. I mean,
just because you can see the pattern all the way through,
I'm like an expert on math major guys.
I've been wearing Felicia clothes and athletic clothes,
like every day of my entire freaking life. And I love it,
but there's things that could be better hearing there.
And there's nothing like that.
Like having a really cute outfit to go in the gym and motivate you to
work out even harder.
So I have like hundreds of pairs of different likings sports for us. Talk,
sorry guys. Intermission.
I'm just changing well coming out in a new outfit.
Okay. All right. So this is a,
I haven't worn this one before. This is all under Armour. Um,
my nose is running. Okay. So
very sticky. Okay. Once you have those up, it's pretty good. The worst.
And I don't know why people promote like,
so it has a zipper in the back self slip. So I don't have to ask you a Honda.
So every time and I'm wearing, um, a size,
small sports bra and all of them and then size
small pants and all of them, but,
and this is a small sports bra top,
but it feels a little bit big again. I like support.
Um, so when I'm running, it's like,
there's a lot of movement and I do a lot of hit trainings or high intensity
interval training, any attrition.
I do a lot of high intensity interval training and
all right. And that's, um,
heavy impacts. So on a lot of the different movements,
like I'll do jump squats. I'll do even mountain climb.
We're seeing the one stationary. It's a lot of balancing. Um, so I like support,
especially when I feel support here and it's not here. It's like,
what's the point? You're just suffocating me here.
But I like the idea of this outfit. I think it was there like this,
like the blocking on the side. Um,
but it's not something I would like go out of my way to get. I'm such a,
like, I'm hard credit. I really am. These outfits are cute,
but like they're not fully there. So I,
the back, all right. Things that like,
I like the matchy-matchy I think that's really cute. I like the,
um, the patterns and the colors with the black.
I like some of the lines on it and some of the cuts on it.
I don't like the fact that there's not enough support up here.
It feels like this has too much give, so it's not really supporting.
And this again, I'm not a fan of mid-rise.
So that's the preference and it feels like it's a little baggy right here.
So that might mean the pants are a little bit small for me. Um, but then again,
if I went to a medium of used skirt, so, um,
and the feel is nice, but it's a little thick of a legging.
I like it when I still feel the compression, but it's still a lighter liking.
So that being said, I think my outfit so far,
that's like my favorite is probably the first one,
just because it looks like it's the most. Wow.
Um, cause it makes my boobs look the best too.
And it also gives me the most support in the first outfit. Uh,
but these ones are okay. Like I would wear them,
but I wouldn't be like stoked to go out and feel like I'm going to get all the
compliments on my outfit, but I would still feel okay wearing them. And again,
I'm not,
I'm not personally a huge fan of the sports bras that are like tank
tops.
I'd rather just wear a sports bra and then wear a tank top over it.
If I want one. All right. Moving on to the next one.
Sorry guys. One sec. Oh wait,
actually I'll just change it here because Herman and Lenay might come up
and that's lovely. Good. Cause I'm changing angle over here.
I'm going to change into the next one.
You can hear me and I'm sorry,
but I just shared so much water and it's
necessary. The good news is,
is that all of these leggings are easy to take off yourself
and like, hold on
and not have like complete struggle.
Even the sports bras, anything to take on and off,
which is what we want.
All right. So I'm trying on another lame
look.
Okay. What are these go up really nice.
I like that.
You guys were really cute.
Oh, you might have a new face.
I'm back. Sorry for the delay. All right.
So these don't go together, but
okay. Where do I begin?
So these are the leggings and they're very
light and easy to put on the field. Nice.
They don't feel like they're, they're like a cotton too.
So for the girls, um,
you can breathe and it doesn't feel like you're going to get too much sweat
going on there. And if you do, it'll dry up. Um,
they are a little bit long.
You can see I'm five foot seven.
And these are like for somebody that's like five, nine,
six foot five, 10, five, nine, five 10. Um,
but so it's the bottom zone warm. And I hate when that happens with leggings,
but overall they're really cute. I love this detail on the side.
Like the lace. I think that's super cute. This is by,
I think it was this beach funny. Yeah.
BB fit is their athletes, your line that they sent me these. Um,
but these feel really good. It's fun to go like this.
And they're just a little too long. I like the overall good.
I think they're really cute. And the booties cute.
I loved the most French foodie. Um,
and then the top is again from hitting the gamma sole.
So this is workout. Um,
so the top is a sports bra.
So let me see, this is the underneath of the top. And then,
um, the other part is like a sheer top on it. It's a cute idea.
And I know before I said, I like a sports bra to be a sports bra,
but this is a super light and it's a
little transparent, which is nice. I like that.
And so I still feel comfortable and flowing.
The only thing that I think they could have done better again is with them.
And the support's pretty good on this one,
but the bunching up of the top right here,
and it goes out a little bit here.
So I'd rather have it slim me more here and then, um,
be flowy. But overall the back is really cute.
And the front sq,
like I would wear this top out throughout the day and then go to the gym minute.
At the end of the day, I'm inspiring you to work out.
I love that. Okay. So this all fits cute.
We love a black outfit. Um,
and then the next one is pretty basic.
This is actually what I'm really going to go work out in.
I've worn this a million times before,
but the only reason I don't like it is because, you know,
love Nike. I think they're great, but it's a little too.
It's not like that's a little ah, in your face. Um,
but I like the neons mans are cool and these shorts have little undies inside.
So you feel like you're not going to flash everybody.
I hate the shorts that are super loose. They don't have the uneasy inside.
And then you're just like, hello and vagina. So this is good. That,
that covers that up. There's little pockets in the back that I don't trust. Um,
and then zipper pockets that I trust more so important for leggings and stuff to
have pockets. That's the one thing that none of these have are pockets.
Where am I going to put my cell phone?
Like they expect us to put it right in here, which isn't ideal.
This is pockets. Oh wait, Nope, nothing.
We're going to put it in phones and we're not carrying a purse around with us at
the gym guys. Come on. Functional,
functional fitness please. Um, but everything is really cute,
not perfect BECU.
I'm going to put this one on so you can see what it looks like with shorts.
And I mostly did all leggings.
I don't know if I started minnows to serve running. I'm like, um,
I mostly did all leggings. I don't know if it's show you shorts,
cause it's not kind of this, whatever we want it to be.
This is my first time doing this. And if you guys like this,
I get boxes all the time of different products and brands that I'm
not afraid to give my honest opinions on.
So if you guys want me to do this more,
I'll give you some feedback on products that you're seeing all the time,
that you can know how it fits and viewable. Instead,
nothing I review is probably very,
very few probably ever going to be perfect in my mind as all my
opinion, but the ones that do you'll be like,
but all these are super cute. Again, disclaimers. I'm going to put this on.
Show you what I'm working on in today. Not a, let me,
this is actually growing on me and these leggings are really easy
to take off. I like that they don't get stuck on your ankles,
even though they are a bit long, uh,
gray shorts on
or the shorts.
Cut up in here. All right. So
here's the last one that I'm going to go to the gym and today.
So as you can see, I either like really low horror, like high,
um, mid-rise, aren't the best for me. I know some people prefer that,
but this is what I'm working out in today.
I like it because it makes my booty look, boom.
And then just the right amount of support that I needed. Boobs look good.
You feel good? They feel supported, secure. Um, and it's pretty,
it's not like something that you can wear to lunch and then go to the
gym. But this is a gym outfit. This is what you work out in. But yeah.
So not this video.
All right. So we got this outfit going. My favorite,
I think of the leggings,
my favorite one to go to the gym and like right now is this one.
As I feel functional, I can get stuff done. I feel supported. I got a sneeze.
All right.
Thank you for those two steps, Leslie. Um, yeah, I dunno.
I like, so like the first one, I love the black one, but not together.
I don't think I would want them together and maybe were a different color color
linking with the black top just to make it more fun. Um,
cause I still want little cute details and things through the gym and stuff.
And this one, I guess I can sit down now. How's uh,
how's the workout. Um, but this one, I feel like, uh,
I can wear it and be safe and all that stuff.
So yeah.
And then with my reviews on that was like five outfits where you guys think that
was enough.
And maybe I should do this every,
every week. Biweekly. I don't know. You guys let me know in the comments,
what you want. What do I say?
I say demand and all supply. I love you guys.
You're amazing. These clothes are super cute.
Great job on building something from nothing. Um, again,
I'm always going to have opinions and little critiques and trying on different
things. I get a ton of makeup and beauty products and all that stuff too.
If you want me to review and do unboxings for those like even home goods.
Oh, I love that. Misses are my favorite. As you can see again,
I think I told you guys in my last video, my stepdad painted that. Um,
how often do I work out?
I try to work out every day,
but I've been slacking in big time. Like I haven't worked out at all this,
this break and I'm playing, I'm going today with her mom and I and your hotness.
But to get me back in the mindset, cause that just been working all day,
but no excuses. I hate excuses. The worst, no excuses. It's my fault.
I'm sorry. I need to go to the gym
and love you guys too. Sweet. Okay. Some of,
I need a moderator for some of these live stream moments,
but yeah, these are honest reviews. I hope that's helpful,
helpful for girls going out and shopping and you know, who knows?
Maybe I can have some of my guy friends come in and do some reviews for workout
clothes for guys too.
Or even just like fashion clothes or even products that are men
and for women. So everybody's, you know,
taken care of. Um, that's just texted me. Oh,
I got a package. I got another package. You guys,
I need to do more videos and show you what I'm getting,
because it's exciting for me.
So it's exciting for you and you can learn about things before you go out and
buy them. Okay. I love you so much. Make sure you subscribe,
turn on the notifications, ring that up. Well,
because I don't have a schedule yet.
Maybe you guys can help me come up with this schedule. Bi-weekly weekly, daily.
I don't know. Let me know. Um, but I like these live streams.
I think they're super fun.
And then I'm going to post them on my page so you can watch later.
And if you're watching later,
because I didn't tell anybody I'm doing this last game,
I was going to do an IgG story, but we forgot and that's life.
But in general, just comment below what you want to see more of. And again,
subscribe. I love you. Okay, bye. I'm going to see if I know how to end this.
How do I add this? Oh, interesting. Okay. Bye.
Yes. And.